daya nada and Edna from Honduras thought
their family have finally made it when
they reached the US and asked for asylum
instead
US officials sent them to Guatemala they
say without their consent the givers
papers to sign
they were in English when we asked what
they were they said they just had our
details on them when we saw the asylum
officer the next day he told us we'd
send our consent to go back to Guatemala
they're not alone the u.s. is now
shipping Hondurans and Salvadorans who
arrived at its border to Guatemala to
apply for asylum there instead more than
100 so far no be ending in for a mouse
they're not being informed of what's
going on in the u.s. they're being told
they're going home and it's a surprise
for them to arrive in Guatemala
president Trump's administration says
the country is safe for asylum seekers
when he questioned that in the 2019
fiscal year Guatemala was actually the
biggest source of migrants detained at
the US border over years it struggled to
keep its own population from leaving let
alone taking care of asylum seekers
coming in here the country's one of the
poorest in the hemisphere and the US
Travel Department itself warns violent
crimes such as armed robbery and murder
is common gang activity such as
extortion violent street crime and
narcotics trafficking is widespread
added to that the asylum system here is
skeletal there are only a dozen case
officers meanwhile NGOs are picking up
the slack little sadly so they're like
US Army let me we've had to provide the
migrants with legal aid medical aid food
everything so we know the state doesn't
have the resources to offer asylum or
even conduct a process we asked the US
Department of Homeland Security for
common we didn't hear back but it's
reached similar agreements with Honduras
and El Salvador hoping to reduce
pressure on a clogged up immigration
system that means asylum seekers could
soon be sent to two of the world's most
violent countries after a night at a
migrant shelter Dayanara Edna and their
children are trying to get the bus fare
together to get home they were dropped
in Guatemala with nothing but the
clothes they're wearing John Holman al
Jazeera Guatemala City